remember in the video about
pseudo-classical classing where I
pointed out that there were two
different categories of code going on in
the car class this is the exact moment
where that distinction becomes extremely
interesting so far we've made it so that
the differentiation code in the subclass
will call out to the differentiation
code available in the superclass but due
to the fact we're using prototype chains
to implement inheritance we also need to
wire up the subclass prototype to the
superclass prototype to allow the
similarity code to be inherited as well
Amy does delegate to Vann dot prototype
but neither Amy nor van dot prototype
have any relationship with car dot
prototype yet in order to set up that
relationship we want to make it so that
van dot prototype delegates to car dot
prototype this is how we are going to
make the shared methods available from
car onto van if we succeed then a lookup
to ami dot move will fall through the
ami object and up to the van prototype
which will fail and finally fall all the
way through to the car prototype ideally
we would be able to update van dot
prototype such that it would delegate
its failed lookups to car dot prototype
in memory we would expect it to work
rather like this the van dot prototype
object should be made to delegate all
the way up to the car dot prototype
object in this way it would be very
similar to car instances because both
would delegate failed lookups to the car
prototype property but this actually
isn't allowed in the official version of
the language instead we're gonna have to
overwrite the originally provided
prototype object with a brand new object
that we create so what object exactly do
we want to be assigning in place of the
old fan dot prototype object it might
surprise you that pseudo-classical
subclasses will work just fine after a
reassignment like this and that's
because the instance delegation is set
up only when the constructor actually
runs this prototype replacement happens
right alongside the constructor
definition and so that's plenty of time
before we actually instantiate any
objects people often propose that van
dot prototype could simply be made to
equal car dot prototype but remember
javascript doesn't do any copying when
you assign one variable or property to
be equal to another one if that was the
case then it would be
impossible to add any methods to the car
prototype that weren't also on the van
prototype and vice versa so adding a van
dot prototype grab would have the effect
of modifying car dot prototype to also
have a dot grab method in short we
definitely don't want our van dot
prototype to be the exact same object in
memory as the car dot prototype object
so instead of making van dot prototype
equal the same exact object as car dot
prototype how can we make sure that the
van prototype will delegate its failed
lookups to car dot prototype fill in the
code for yourself